[Music]
so hello everybody my name is Kenny ha
I'm a program manager from being a on
expanding team so today I want to do so
being visual search so visual search is
a new technique you looking for
information based on image or acquiring
patterning material query so in being we
have our three features the first one is
a visual search second is the objection
and surveys image annotation so here are
some pictures for the visual search we
can support generic commercial search
and we can also support Second Amendment
which was such tragic fashion home
furniture and people and here's our
unknown food of above issue search like
what are the tech notes behind them we
train DNA models for it and we use
optimized productor combination for you
so the second feature is our detection
which is not not shipped yet but we are
ship we assume so objection in first
release we support eight categories for
fashion as you can see we show how spot
here and use a critical transport we
will draw the bounding box automatically
and after user draw the bounding box we
got shooter related products or images
here and here's another demo for the
home furnishing currently we are working
on their training model for it so we use
our five senses as in which is very
popular in industry he'll train the
model and we also use their online GPO
to support a nice mirror like user can
input any camera image to to education
and our latency is less than 100
milliseconds so last one is a image
annotation so while we do image
annotation it is the intent is to
predictor the content of image like her
for this talk we can know which dock it
is another hour we can know what fro it
is and also we can know the landmark the
food and a celebrity so here's some
examples actually we work on NHIN herbs
and arrows
so this is a another hood for image
annotation so we have to highlight so
the model based annotation and the
ritual based model annotation so
motivational means we train a model and
input image based on the model we can
know what are the category of the image
this is a model based and inertia based
means we can use any not that knowledge
another being we have a huge index then
we can know what image we can know what
is the related images qurbani through
this image and then we know the
annotations belong to those similar
images then we can predict what are the
annotations for those image so that's
pretty much what we have thank you